No Bible read today?
no problem we read them together
this Bible passage helps me again and again
when worries take me completely
when fears block my view and make it difficult to trust God
maybe this Bible passage will help you too you must know it
no matter where you are in the car in bed
in the train,
ey listen to it and let it go over you
"A song from David"
October 23
the Lord is my shepherd
nothing will be missing
he feeds me in lushs and leads me to fresh springs
he gives me new strength
he guides me in safe ways and makes his name so that all honor
and even when going through dark valleys
I fear no misfortune
For you Lord are with me
your shepherd's crook gives me protection and comfort
you invite me and set the table for me in front of my enemies
you greet me like a householder his guest and fill my cup to the brim
your goodness and love accompany me day after day
in your house I may stay
all my life
I want to say a short prayer
when you are plagued by worries and fears again and again
Father thank you so much for the person listening here right now
and I know that you see our situations Jesus
you know our hearts and I know that you don't care how we are
i believe in it
that you have a solution to our problems
I believe that you are the solution!
Jesus you are the answer to our longing
I know that you have always heard me and also heard me again today
and I also pray that the person who is listening
knows that she can speak to you and can trust firmly in it
that you hear Jesus
in Jesus' name Amen